Đần đầu tiên sau hôm năm.
Nữ Lua Grasseni, Nhi Khoch tại Kam Chắc Kha, Ngà, đã phung trào dữ dội với cuộc cho cao sống nghiệm
met, sau trận động đất tám vì tám độ sảy ra ngày 3 môi tháng bài.
Đây được xem là trận động đất mạnh nhất tại khu vực này trong hương bệm mi năm.
Lời sống thần lan xa tế hao ai vào bởi vì bị.
Hóa động địa trấn đã kích hoạt lần sau nữ lượng mới tại vĩnh Đông Ngà,
với các nữ lượng lớn như, Lưu Chép Scaya, Succa, Suvia Lực,
và Karimski, củng tăng đức phung trào.
Các chuyên gia nhận định, lộn đất không chỉ tắt độ đến bệm mặt,
mà còn vui bến đổi sâu trong hệ thống mắt mà,
làm thức tình những nữ lượng ngủyên hàng thế kiện.
Vậy lượng mất cảnh báo hành không lên Kam, cho thấy nguy cơ cho nữ lượng với giản đoạn sau thông,
vành hưởng môi trường dọc lưỡn.
Với chức ngà, quính cáo nữ lượng của vực hoạt động lưỡn,
trong bán kính in nhất 1 kí lúc mẹ để đảm bảo an toàn.